if we want to find out like what F of
two is all we have to do is replace two
with X on the right side of the equation
so that's called direct substitution
what I'm going to show you is a
synthetic substitution and okay this is
a the remainder theorem and what the
remainder theorem is it tells us okay
let's go ahead and do synthetic division
like we did in a previous video we're
going to divide 2x cubed minus 5 x
squared plus 4x minus 1 using 2 so I'm
going to bring down the leading
coefficient I'm going to multiply on the
diagonal I'm going to add straight down
I'm gonna multiply on the diagonal add
straight down multiply on the diagonal
and add straight down now this number I
get here at the end this is our
remainder right so the remainder theorem
tells us that this remainder this number
that we get here at the end is the same
thing we would get if we were to
directly substitute 2 into our
polynomial here on the right so let's
just see if we can confirm that 2 cubed
minus 5 times 2 squared plus 4 times 2
minus 1/2 cubed is 8 times 2 is 16 2
squared is 4 times 5 is 20 4 times 2 is
8 minus 1 so this is negative 4 plus 8
is positive 4 minus 1 equals 3 the same
thing we got here this is supposed to be
a quicker method okay a lot of times you
might have you know even a longer
polynomial you might be working with you
know fractions and it can be a little
bit more challenging to do the direct
substitution method so by using the
remainder theorem which is basically
like doing a synthetic division whatever
you end up with here that's your
remainder and if you get zero for your
remainder all that tells you is that
that's where it crosses the x axis so if
this came out to zero that would tell us
that at one two this graph is crossing
at x equals two what the two of three
means just that at when X is 2 the y
coordinate is going to be 3 so
just a point on our polynomial point on
our graph so the remainder theorem is
really just like doing direct
substitution in a faster format and
again if you get zero remainder that
just tells you that the y-value is zero
f of X is y and that's an x-intercept
but in this case it came out to three so
it just means that this point is 2 comma
3 on our graph so this has been how to
work with the remainder theorem I'll see
you in the next video